what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
today from our friend the cosmic wonder
black panther 2 wakanda forever d23
trailer footage breakdown they only
played it for the people over at d23 so
we did not get an opportunity to see it
ourselves i'm sure we'll get it
relatively soon but meantime let's see
what is being described john how are you
i am awake how are you oh that's a
that's a response i'm good thank you
leave a like let's see what's going on
[Music]
so in this video we'll be diving into
detail about the new black panther
wakanda forever trailer footage that was
shown at d23 and breaking it down so
let's break down the new footage that
was only shown to the attendees of d23
where we'll see how strong wakanda still
is without their king how strong neymar
is and how doom might actually be behind
everything and this footage actually did
give us kind of a more clearer picture
of what exactly is going on in wakanda
forever yes we know that it's
essentially going to be a battle between
wakanda and neymar and his people
however it looks like there is
definitely more to it than that the
trailer starts off by queen ramonda
going to the united nations assembly at
the u.n being questioned by multiple
representatives including a new
character played by richard schiff queen
ramonda is being asked about vibranium
and how it can be used as a weapon for
mass destruction facing criticism for
its threat to global order the french
representative asked about how dangerous
it is to use vibraniums for weapons of
mass destruction since vibranium is
virtually undetectable by actual metal
detectors
assures the assembly that wakanda has a
policy to never trade vibranium not
under any circumstances not because the
element is dangerous on its own but
because of the potential it holds in
other people's hands yeah they go like
that that's actually really fascinating
because the first black panther ended
with t'challa coming forward and being
like hey
we're here to work with you all
and then this trailer opens with you
guys are a threat we're here to work
with you but not that much what is this
vibranium and how dangerous is this
vibranium to us actually like that
political approach to it that's the last
thing you would think of about this
movie due to all the emotional
circumstances but i think that's a
really nice sort of plot thread to keep
alive because of course everyone's going
to be descending on wakanda for
resources now black panther 3 wakanda
versus the us let's go now as she says
this the scene cuts to another scene
that takes place in a wakandan research
center we see a group of people with
guns infiltrate the facility in search
of vibranium tools they find a vibranium
covered wall and markings and when they
get to it and activate it the markings
light up meanwhile it cuts back to the
queen saying at the un you perform
civility here but we know what you
whisper in your halls of leadership and
in your military facilities the king is
dead the black panther is gone they have
lost their protectors now while she's
saying this it keeps cutting back and
forth between that scene on the research
center but the dora milaje appears and
actually one of the dora milaji was
undercover disguised as a research
assistant it then shows the dora malaji
led by okoye going off against the
mercenaries who broke into the research
facility and as queen raimondo's talking
comes to an end we actually see the dora
melange enter the assembly with the
mercenaries that they have defeated
that's a boss move i'm actually liking
the way this is being set up right now
because you know obviously they're going
to deal with the passing of t'challa i
imagine they'll acknowledge that early
on in the film part of the world of
wakanda of what they're dealing with is
having to regain their strength and
especially from the public optics as
well because right now with the death of
their king as raimondo's stated in this
trailer wakanda is now vulnerable you
see that they're being threatened
politically in a way and then you've got
the situation the mercenaries and we
haven't gotten to the spot with neymar
yet people of wakanda having to regain
that strength when they were looked at
as like the strongest before yeah to
kind of recoup and save face in the wake
of this while they figure out what to do
because it's like as you're describing
this i'm just seeing it all in my head
and kind of feeling the tension
potentially of what that scene would
feel like and i love the the cutting
like i don't know how to play in the
movie but the idea that basically while
this is going down and while you could
probably point to somebody at this
assembly for carrying out this operation
here they are bringing in you know the
uh mercenaries they've just busted you
know into this moment of tension but
also you know ramonda is a powerful
character even though we don't really
see a ton of that early on and so i feel
like we'll definitely get a sense for
that here from here the trailer showed
old shots from the first trailer it
includes a glowing sunset of wakanda and
t'challa's funeral and then we get more
footage in this time of namor it appears
that queen raimonda and neymor are
actually meeting with each other however
umbaku quickly attacks neymar with a
staff which immediately smashes to
pieces and when embakku actually hits
neymar namor doesn't even react to the
attack
damn you're wondering if neymar is going
to be big bad and strong the answer is
yes namor and embaku and demonstrating
the strength looks like that could be a
tease for embaku becoming the black
panther because he would have to take
some herb uh-oh in order to rival the
strength
of a specific villain but the trailer
ends with an explosion on a city bridge
and it ends with a shot of the new black
panther and the final line that says
show them who we are and that was the
exclusive clip trailer that was shown at
d23 this past saturday now there are
some very important things to break down
here one is that you have to remember
what happened at the very end of the
first black panther film t'challa
addressed the united nations and said
that he was going to open wakanda's
resources to the rest of the world
everyone kind of laughed thinking that
wakanda was indeed a third world country
and had nothing to offer and it ended
with t'challa just kind of smiling
knowing that his country is actually the
richest in the world but now everybody
knows about wakanda and everybody knows
about vibranium and the world wants it
however wakanda refuses to trade it they
even bring those soldiers who attack the
research facility to the united nations
to prove a point and the point is
wakanda can handle their own even though
black panther and t'challa are gone so
with riri williams are they establishing
that she's part of that research
facility the ones that the mercenaries
tried overtaking and she was part of
that group initially i could definitely
see that yeah and then maybe that's how
they get her you know into the you know
laboratory hq back at wakanda or
something like that so maybe she's
possibly partially responsible for her
helping to locate where this vibranium
is that people are looking for yeah it
could be i feel like we're gonna get so
much vibranium action in this film
decking people out with vibranium you
know suits and stuff like that it's
probably a next stage element for
upgrading our warriors in wakanda yeah
you gotta go bigger and better for the
sequel and after all the vibranium
gadgetry we got the first time i can
only imagine what they'll do this time
because yeah you gotta expand and
innovate now one of the most important
things to focus on in this clip was the
fact that a wakandan research facility
was in fact invaded this means that
since wakanda will not trade vibranium
with the rest of the world some of the
world is trying to take it by force and
this very very well could be other
countries trying to take it but it also
makes you wonder who else wants it and
most of you probably know who i'm
thinking about right now victor von doom
aka dr doom there have been rumors going
around for a while now that doctor doom
will be in wakanda forever in some way
shape or form however i would like to
point out that this is not confirmed yet
we do not know for sure if he is going
to be in the film even though he is
rumored to be appearing in a
post-credits scene we know that rumors
can be wrong look at what happened at
d23 however saying that i do think it
makes a reality
especially if we follow the do-more
storyline from the comics this is very
important to know and i'll explain why
in the doom war story line doom helps
the disturbed gain access to wakanda
they actually dethrone t'challa and
shuri and completely take over wakanda
and they even put the x-men storm on
trial because she is t'challa's wife in
the comics at this point in time at
least and what's interesting is we
learned that doom actually infected all
of wakandans with food and water putting
nanites in them allowing him to use
these nanites and people basically as
cameras t'challa being the black panther
has heightened senses so he realizes
caught on to what was happening and
didn't partake of any food or water and
told shuri as well so she didn't and the
both of them managed to escape however
they quickly realized that doctor doom
was only helping the distillery so he
could get into wakanda and get vibranium
and the reason why is because dr doom
has discovered a secret that nobody else
has known it can amplify mystical
energies and its effects are infinite
all right yeah i mean i like what you're
going at here with dr doom and explain
all the reasoning i highly doubt that it
would be
99
of what is being described over pulling
from the comics here i feel like it'll
probably be a post-credits scene and
that's somehow the thing between the war
with neymar
and wakanda that he helped orchestrate
that in some way you'll probably reveal
that he was behind it but i feel like we
probably won't get any explanation other
than he was looking for a vibranium but
we probably won't get any real detailed
explanation as to as to why yeah until
like later on down the road there's got
to be another motive for why namor
himself wants vibranium like and that's
more of my question versus being like dr
doom told me to i feel like there's got
to be a personal reason for neymar to be
involved well yeah and there could be
some kind of bigger more uh convoluted
plot like i almost expect dr doom to
have his strings pulling inside the u.n
as well maybe so maybe this is like some
kind of false conflict that's been sort
of orchestrated behind the scenes or
something to you know make them fight
each other and weaken each other the
wakandans and the atlanteans and all
that for somebody like dr doom who is
already extremely strong with mystical
energies it can basically make dr doom
unstoppable this is why i think in
wakanda forever doctor doom could be
behind one of the groups at least trying
to break into wakanda to steal some
vibranium in fact he could even be
behind namor whether that's directly or
indirectly like i said in the comics
doom helps that a story to gain access
to wakanda's vibranium he helps them
essentially take over wakanda the same
could be happening with neymar and the
atlanteans although they won't be
atlanteans in the film they're more
likely going to be an ancient aztec or
mayan race also another scene that was
shown during this clip at d23 was riri
williams aka ironheart conducting
projects on vibranium and from what we
know the projects are her making
machines that can actually detect
vibranium in the ocean now this could
clearly upset two people here one the
wakandans and two namor obviously
wakanda does not want vibranium getting
out to the public and obviously namor
does not want people going around his
parts of the ocean discovering his
people this is most likely how riri
williams actually ends up in wakanda but
this could actually be a part of doom's
plan send people into the ocean to look
for vibranium using the technology that
riri williams created to make neymar mad
and go after wakanda then once wakanda
has been flooded because we've seen that
in the first trailer and basically
wakanda taken out doctor doom can then
go in and get vibranium what if riri
williams is not part of that research
facility
and is part of the people like she's
being used
by the people who are searching for the
vibranium like the bad people because
i'm trying to think like why she
building an iron hard suit is that so
she can get involved in the fight at the
like ending battle or something or does
she build the vibranium does she build
her iron hard suit to escape from the
situation she's held into yeah instead
of you know being used i'm gonna just
make my own instrument that'll give me
the power to break free of all you guys
well i feel like she's probably being
held captive in some way because that
scene is
mirroring the iron man cave scene so
much which was built from having to
escape so i feel like she's being held
captive and forced to do something she
doesn't want to do and so she builds the
suit so because of the fact that it's
emulating so much of that that's why i'm
kind of thinking that maybe she's
escaping from something well the box of
scraps it doesn't make sense to not have
doctor doom in the mcu as he is one of
the main villains of the fantastic four
and he is pretty much the main villain
of secret wars we get god emperor doom
in that story line but let me know what
you think about this in the comments
down below do you think doom could be
behind atlantis vs wakanda and of course
be sure to let me know what you think
about this new footage that was shown at
d23 in the comments down below please
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the mcu
and for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching
all right well that is some information
we got
look at that all right guys well thank
you for being here uh subscribe to
cosmic wonder you can subscribe to real
rejects and hey let's end this video
with a pic
tyler hey oh look out looked up your
name on urban dictionary and here's what
it is tyler's are hard to put in words
they pose many great characteristics
some of those characteristics include
being a very loving person oh that is
very accurate of tyler hey he's a cuddly
teddy bear a great sense of humor he is
a perverted sense of humor
amazing personality a little too much
personality some might say a little over
imposing
great looks couldn't even look at him
because my ego was deteriorating and
talented multitasker this tyler is for
sure with the best of them tyler is the
name of someone that has great talent
whether it be in sports music or the
fine arts well he does have an exquisite
palette of tests all of the above
overall everybody wants a tyler in their
life or to be a tyler i wish i was a
tyler there's only one tyler in my life
and that is a tyler hake and i gotta
tell you we are happy to have you here
tyler you are the bomb and i love you so
much buddy happy as a hague to have you
i hope you've been doing well and hit me
up sometime we'll talk soon
[Music]